well we know the Consumer Electronics
Show is back in town our good friend Dr
Frank is back doctor Frank God love you
man it's so great
we have so much stuff to talk about
we're starting with some kind of fancy
TV or something we're starting actually
with laptops oh it's a laptops you know
laptop's very important right yeah and I
have one oh yeah this is by LG it's the
LG Grim style it's created for people
who really love and want to express
their unique style and the reason we
look at this look at this see the
iridescence oh yeah okay so it comes in
16 inch and 14 inch and here's what Al
Gino LG's famous for OLED OLED is a
organic light emitting diode technology
nothing better on the planet at this
point to watch television they put it
now on the laptop get out yeah so that's
an OLED screen can you imagine that and
this is uh Windows oh yeah absolutely
okay it is it absolutely is Windows and
it's got a illuminated touch pad which
is great and I let our audience yeah
because this thing booted up pretty
quickly oh yeah it really did yep so it
has a refresh rate you know a 13th gen
Intel processor it's got everything the
thing is if you want a laptop premium
laptop that's lightweight with
performance the LG gram is the way to go
all right and let's move on to it okay
some kind of a projector yeah this is by
Epson this is wonderful this projector
is so unique because it brings families
together it creates memory you know it's
great for movie night right or Sports
look how small this thing is and you can
take it with you Nate that's backyard
that's wherever yeah backyard neighbors
friends right whatever here's the most
important thing this thing has a
thousand lumens that lumens is a measure
of brightness yeah okay most of the
projectors in this price range are 100
to 200 this is one thousand it's it's
9.99 but starting January 8th the price
drops to 7.99
if you can hang on just another week
until Sunday you're in good shape
absolutely and of course you know it's
got basic white based on Wi-Fi Android
TV so all the content ready to go Etc by
Epson excellent what's next so this is
what this is called what meds it's the
world's first wallet enabled health
application for medication management
that's a beauty so 50 million people
with Medicare and Drug coverage and 40
million caregivers this information now
is available to you know all of your
doctors Etc people in the healthcare
profession say what are your meds you
simply you have that and the app will be
available shortly so this is an app that
helps you control your health care yeah
yep and it gives you the up-to-date list
and again you can share with anybody and
it basically it's what'smeds.com awesome
yeah okay but wait there's more oh yeah
there's more absolutely so now the next
product this is by free to move it's by
stalantis okay and free to move
basically uh what's interesting about
the the product is it's an Innovative
new service providing a global Mobility
Hub so let's say you want to buy an EV
but you're not sure right right okay so
Freedom move will allow you to basically
schedule that vehicle for a day a week
or a month how about that oh okay so
then you derive it right and you decide
exactly you know what this is great you
have an opportunity to look at these and
that's important so they're going to be
available shortly in Washington DC and
Denver they're opening soon in Dallas
but they plan for 200 more hubs around
the world they're very big in in Europe
now I got to tell you something about
this last product we're talking about
flash drives right you and I remember
the Consumer Electronics Show when there
was a 64 megabyte flash drive and it was
like Revolution wow You'll never have
anything that will hold more than 64
megabytes and this is the next gen
fastest USB 3.2 Drive available it's by
Kingston it comes in type c and type a
right which is important right rugged
case speed is up to 100 or to a thousand
megabytes read speeds and so forth and
they have it up to one terabyte so you
can have your your entire data in your
pocket and unbelievable I mean are you
getting a terabyte on a flash drive yeah
terabyte that's crazy that's crazy yeah
but no other flash drive in the market
is as fast as this is by Kingston okay
that's very important look at the price
yeah starting at 43 bucks crazy isn't it
but it's so good to see you right Dr
Frank Maggiano the gadget guy thanks for
having me buddy